were you working with Orlando Brown on
that show yeah
yeah when you were working with him did
you have any idea that he was crazy as
he is Orlando's not crazy in my opinion
Orlando is one of the most talented
individuals very talented guys
his interview his life are [__] wild
though I think he does that because he's
he's a he's an intelligent person he
knows what he's doing he knows how to
get clicks he knows how to get he knows
what it takes he's like a walk yeah he's
definitely a viral yeah he want to go
viral that's all it is I don't believe
he's he's not crazy at all right Orlando
got sense believe me when I tell you the
boy got all the sense y'all could thank
that man some people could have too much
sense though maybe that that could be it
yeah but one thing about it that boy
ain't crazy if he has me he know what he
doing so when you guys you were working
with Orlando on uh That's So Raven did
you guys have a close relationship back
then yeah that was my dog man like he
was in the music so you know I mean one
of the people that helped me learn how
to like really write raps and you know
what I mean was a big bro figure as well
like kind of you know I mean he was a
dope dude growing up and still is in my
opinion like um
he's entertaining if if you don't know
him personally if you ain't seen item
that I've seen and sorry for you but I
know that [__] in the real way so he's
entertaining I I don't know I mean he
doesn't seem like a bad guy absolutely
he'd be saying some wild [__] bro
yeah I mean but a lot of [__] do they
just pay attention to him because like
oh he was on Disney so well he's not
he's not allowed to say wow [__] that's
true you know do you ever feel like that
you had to shake that for a while being
like the Disney Channel guy oh yeah
absolutely but one thing about it is
I've always been me like if you believe
I'm a Disney Channel [__] that means
that's just what you believe I don't
really give a damn life I was just
wondering because like you know I feel
like if you're
you know we've seen so many people come
from the Disney Channel on the pop side
but not as much on the hip-hop side yeah
so it's something kind of different you
know yeah most definitely I mean for me
if people do their research with me to
SC that I started with the hip-hop and I
started rapping I was coming up rapping
Bow Wow I did the Apollo I went through
all I did uh Sally uh Ricky Lake Jenny
Jones all these yeah YouTube's on all
those shows man I'm oh gee Kev I'm not
[__] man I'm nosy man you ain't seen
Role Models man
you were on
Jenny Jones and Ricky Lake yes bro
that's the one too Raphael I did all of
them Sally Jesse too Sally I did them
all man Jesus I'm a big dog man I've
been doing this [__] man I'm trying to
tell you you were on there just like as
like the kid rapper I was rapping yeah
yeah I even did a [__] I don't rap no
Maury what come on man I'm I'm a Og man
you've been on I didn't did it all in
all the most Unthinkable places if you
think about it bro Maury who else isn't
rap no more I don't know man come on man
I was rapping a lot of people needed to
wrap it up on Maury yeah that was the
problem they said Bobby said these [__]
can't wrap it up so you just gonna spit
a rat [__] it jeez what was up for you
as a kid which show was like the coolest
for you to like be on because that's
gotta out of those talk shows uh talk
shows okay yeah the ones we just talked
about the you know the toxic ones
I'll probably have to say Maury just
because I was a little bit older and I
was more familiar with Maury by the time
I wasn't that familiar with Sally and
Ricky Lake and Jane Jones When I had
went on them I was still like five years
old at that time five six years old yeah
somewhere like that but by the time I
made it the Maury I had already seen
Maury on TV like I you could probably
see us it's somewhere on the internet
you'll see me I had a more I did the
Mori impression you know I mean like I
did the whole I [__] B when uh when
the baby ain't theirs when they find out
it's funny I did that 20 years ago
before it became a man right before it
was a thing yeah boy I did that 20 years
ago on Mario like you can find that
somewhere I swear to God like it's funny
as hell to just see that type of [__]
now but yeah like if you think back to
those like talk shows like some of the
premises of those shows were absolutely
wild yeah absolutely it'd be like a
trans member of the KKK reveals that his
son is black next
and you'd be like whoa what the [__]
where did I put these [__] people
you know it too it'd be like a nah for
sure for soda nah for sure shout out to
you just didn't make it to Jerry nah I
made it this year I'm kind of okay with
that you're okay with that I'm okay with
that shout out to Jerry damn that's not
Jerry but I'm glad I didn't make it